[Music]
what's up wisecrack jared here during
these highly unstable times one of the
few things we can know for certain is
that you have recently seen Tiger King
another certainty is that you can't stop
thinking about Joe exotics music videos
this Netflix show about feuding owners
of Genki zoos has dominated our brain
space consumed our weekly all staff
meetings and even resulted in the
occasional Caryl Baskin themed nightmare
the show is addicting baffling and far
juicier than any expired Walmart meat
much of the media attention surrounding
Tiger King has appropriately focused on
Joe exotic the endlessly fascinating
gun-toting polyamorous redneck now
incarcerated big cat owner
unsurprisingly he's become something of
a cultural icon in his own right
similarly his fellow big cat dealer dr.
Antle has claimed that he's received a
wild influx of male and female
applicants eager to join his sprawling
harem of scantily clad Tiger trainers
keep in mind these folks live and labor
in squalor earned somewhere between $0
and way less than minimum wage and still
behave like they have the best damn job
in the world I'm doing Tiger shows and
while I certainly understand the appeal
of becoming besties with a cat that
might murder me I still have so many
questions like what why how luckily one
of our other side obsessions can answer
the question of what makes someone like
Joe exotic or doc antle's so addicting
to Netflix audiences and wayward
teenagers alike specifically holes now
the word cult might stir images of
barefoot Manson chicks rather than
pro-bono Tiger trainers but even if the
subjects of Tiger King are not running
full fledged cults the psychology of
cults can do a whole lot to explain how
perfectly ordinary people become
unflinchingly loyal to a guy with a soul
patch or someone who changed their last
name to exotic and above all it poses
the question could you dear viewer even
wind up training Tigers for zero dollars
an hour after all are we not all
susceptible to cult-like behaviors let's
find out in this wisecrack edition on
Tiger King as always spoilers ahead for
the most banana's TV show you've seen
since going into
but before we get into it I want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
footmouse it's just such a huge
advantage but it's still all about skill
mouth just raises the skills gap okay
yeah we're not serious this video is
actually sponsored by raid Shadow
legends for those of you that don't know
raid Shadow Legends is a free hero
collector RPG available on mobile and PC
you can level up your champions fight
epic boss battles and challenge other
players in PvP battles if you haven't
played it yet now is the perfect time to
start their new player rewards program
just got extended from 90 to 180 days
for the first hundred 80 days you log in
you'll be rewarded with energy refills
gems silver and even epic champions sill
of the Drake click the link in the
description to download the game today
use our link within the next 30 days and
you'll get a hundred thousand silver 50
gems and energy refill and a free epic
champion the executioner all this
treasure will be waiting for you here
the rewards will be available only for
new players and now back to the show if
you somehow haven't seen it Tiger King
immerses us in the very weird world of
big cat owners primarily Joe exotic a
Kansas man come Oklahoman who operates a
small zoo for lions tigers and other
animals that definitely don't belong in
cages the narrative which becomes
exponentially more bonkers by the minute
details a growing feud between Joe and
Carol Baskin a devoted lover of animal
prints who operates big cat rescue a
sanctuary
apparently dedicated to ending the
selling breeding and commercial cuddling
of this adorable tiger cub the feud
escalates to the point where send your
exotic apparently hires someone to
murder Carol and act that combined with
his big hat industrial complex lands him
over two decades in prison along the way
he acquires three young male husbands
one of whom dies tragically oh and also
Carol's millionaire second husband
vanishes into thin air also Joe runs the
world's weirdest presidential campaign
and they seize out paid for by the
committee of Joe exotic speaks for
America Carol runs the world's weirdest
Facebook livestream and again doc runs a
literal harem also the music videos so
many music videos
some of which honestly and please don't
roast me for this or maybe not that bad
most of the tiger king cultural
discourse has dealt with Mema fiying Joe
exotic and the other cast of absurd
characters what we found most
interesting though wasn't Joe's
political aspirations or even Carroll's
potentially murderous streak rather
we're finding ourselves obsessed with
the way two of the central characters
Joe exotic and Doc antal built and
maintained their avid followings of low
to no paid workers and fans that is to
say how did these two borderline
lunatics effectively become kind of cult
II before we can prove that Joe exotic
is actually Oklahoma's finest cultists
to ever cult we need to look at what
defines a cult in the first place as is
the case with most complicated and
fascinating things the definition of the
word cult is notoriously slippery which
is why people have written entire
academic papers debating said definition
in summation for a long time the word
cult was relatively neutral term
associated with conventional religious
or spiritual groups such as a cult of a
Roman god in the 19th century the word
began to develop a pejorative street
being used to describe excessive
devotion as cults became more common in
the 70s anti-cult fervor also rose and
cultural fascination surrounding cult
has remained strong sense for ease of
understanding we're going to define
colds by their common characteristics as
defined by psychiatrist and harvard
professor robert jay lifton in his paper
cult formation in it he delineated the
three central characteristics of a
destructive cult these were one a
charismatic leader two coercive
persuasion or thought reform ie
brainwashing and three economic sexual
and other exploitation of group members
by the leader and their inner circle
we'd argue that the organisations of Joe
exotic and Doc antal both exhibit some
level of these three characteristics
he's got his little cult and I got my
little cult when it comes to number one
charismatic leaders Tiger King does not
disappoint most notably of course we
have Joe exotic a dude with enough
redneck charm to convince not one but
two apparently straight men young enough
to be his son to enter a three-way
marriage with him and his glorious
mullet cult leaders whether they're
Charles Manson or a kool-aid slurping
Jim Jones demand to be the center of a
tent
Joe exotic marketed his zoo as his own
personal stage he thrived on being
filmed
even when said filming was of intensely
incriminating acts like threatening
murder cult leaders demand adoration and
through a mix of charisma
self-confidence and seductive tendencies
inspire an almost pathological devotion
in their followers it's not surprising
that they often take on vaguely
religious monikers from nexium leader
Keith Rainier who went by Vanguard to
the source family leader father Yod it's
not just about picking a super cool and
not lame at all name like Joe exotic or
bhagavad though bhagavad means that
you're a friend of God cult leaders
according to psychotherapist Daniel Shaw
claim their power Visa be their
traumatic narcissism which he explains
as a version of self-centeredness and
self aggrandizing far more sinister than
anything you could accuse your typical
imagine singing celebrity of Forshaw
traumatic narcissism can be summarized
as the objectification of one person in
a relationship as the means of enforcing
the dominance of the subjectivity of the
other that is to say when you become
involved with a traumatically
narcissistic person you surrender the
right to have your own mind and
perspective you internalize the
narcissist doctrine and worldview and
learn to dread thinking for yourself
that just about sums up a lot of the
relationships we see in Tiger King with
both Joe exotic and de Cantel
effectively acting as preachers of the
sacred gospel of the tiger they happily
use their charisma and sexual power to
take advantage of vulnerable people
under the guise of saving these
admittedly amazing animals as all
traumatizing narcissus do doc and Joe
think that their emotional needs Trump
all others maybe ask me what's wrong but
he only spends five seconds listening
and then he'll walk out on me this
brings us to point number two coercive
persuasion or thought reform this point
is a little complicated because for the
most part we don't really see the
indoctrination process as the followers
seemed pretty acclimated to hash tag
cult life by the time we meet them but
we do see the implications of that
indoctrination in the way Joe and Doc
expect their employees to sacrifice
everything in order to work toward their
designated goal whether that goal is
actually saving Tigers or merely
improving their down trodden menagerie
this almost beside the point
arguably the best evidence of Joe exotic
and Doc antle's exquisite hold over
there
followers comes in a few specific
moments first doc makes his inner circle
all change their names as if to divorce
themselves from their prior identities a
common tactic in colts china came right
after I came her name is Miss Michelle
moksha
was named Meredith Rajan II when I met
her her name was Renee I had my name
legally changed to Bala for many years
changing your name it's a very quick way
to change everything else about you then
there's when Joe's employee loses an arm
and rather than electing to spend two
years getting reconstructive surgery
instead gets it amputated and goes back
to work after five days so as not to
hurt the collective cause of saving
Tigers now here's where things get a
little complicated because lots of non
coltie people make sacrifices for the
greater good
think of a protester putting themselves
in front of a tank or a healthcare
worker putting themselves in harm's way
to help their patients but there's a
pretty important difference that is the
huge discrepancy in who is benefiting
from your sacrifice sure the Tigers but
most importantly Joe and his bank
account and never gonna financially
recover from this and this kind of logic
will inform a lot more than just cults
but we'll get there similarly doc antal
expects the 24/7 work efforts of those
unfortunate enough to be in his harem
unless of course they're recovering from
a boob job he coerced them into getting
they were pushing me to get implants but
how do they get away with this it all
comes down to the demographic cult
leaders seek out typically people who
join cults are young isolated and in
transitory moments of their life in fact
psychiatrist John G Clark jr. notes that
cult leaders will frequent bus stations
airports campuses libraries rallies
anywhere that unattached persons are
likely to be passing through and
actually literally see Joe doing when he
recruits this woman into his Tigra cult
in her onscreen interview Barbara Fisher
notes that doc antal tended to go for
women who were virgins that is
uninitiated into the world of sexual
relationships rendering them far more
likely to fall into his orbit there was
a certain personality of woman that he
wanted they were virgins are close to
virgins what's more cult leaders as
traumatic narcissists are notoriously
mercurial using their endlessly
vacillating emotions to confuse
disorient and manipulate their followers
we see this with Joe whose narcissism
seems only to be augmented when he's on
camera sometimes he'll be kind and
inspiring sometimes he'll lash out
cruelly at his employees even firing
them purely to generate drama like a
real housewife on steroids then there's
the third criteria exploitation of one's
followers in economic sexual and other
assorted arenas this most commonly
occurs when cult leaders overwork their
followers in the cults family business
whether that means dumpster diving for
food like a Manson girl or helping to
run the multi-level marketing cult
nexium or working as housekeeper for the
lesser-known father divine this is doc
and Joe to a tee you're working every
day yeah typically and as we see in
Tiger King these work days are long and
grueling leaving followers to exhausted
to do anything but go to sleep and dream
about their beloved leaders this state
of over work puts their followers in a
chronic state of sensory deprivation
which makes them easier to manipulate
and control arguably spending 12 hours a
day seven days a week shoveling Tiger
poo and manicuring Tiger lawns makes you
more pliable more obedient and some cult
experts would say can even potentially
alter your brain chemistry on the
economic exploitation front all of these
people make close to no money how much
$200 a week enriching their leaders but
also inhibiting their ability to leave
then of course there's the sex stuff Joe
and Doc seem to exclusively prey on
young people who lack solidified sexual
identities and in Joe's case even
potentially using drugs to coerce them
into sex when you have a charismatic
leader who has separated you from the
outside world and forces you to work
hard for almost zero dollars can you
really be in a willing and healthy
sexual relationship we say nah and most
shrinks would probably back us up on
this so with these three sucky criteria
fulfilled world
with one big looming question how do
these leaders convince their members to
stay that's where we get to the real
nucleus of what makes a cult and if it
weren't so sad and potentially lethal it
could be kind of beautiful human beings
are almost genetically engineered to
seek a purpose in life for centuries
that purpose was primarily realized in
mainstream religion likely a big reason
that cult sprang up with such force in
1970s America was the downturn of
mainstream religiosity that followed the
baby boomer hippie awakening of the 60s
when you lose weekly church sermons
about God's love you need a replacement
thousands of Americans found that
replacement in cults whether it was the
Manson Family Scientology children of
God or so on each of these groups
featured a charismatic leader who
offered critically a purpose to their
followers for the Manson Family that
purpose was free love with a side of
race war for Scientology it was
advancing through bogus classes until
you could learn the even more bogus
secrets of the universe he'd say the
fifth invaders are out there and this is
how they addressed him this is how they
talk for the Heaven's Gate cult it was
the promise of transcendence into an
extraterrestrial spacecraft for Jim
Jones's unfortunate followers it was the
doctrine of so-called revolutionary
suicide and if you're a tiger trainer at
the ritzy Myrtle Beach Safari or the
janky GW Zoo you are following the
gospel of saving the Tigers as Noble as
that goal may actually be and Joe exotic
especially makes a borderline convincing
case for that goal in the early episodes
of the show expressing a genuine desire
to save big cats from extinction via
shopping mall cuddling sessions
achieving a higher purpose is lovely we
wish it for all of you but please God
not at the expense of your favorite arm
of course we haven't really dealt with
Carol Baskin who was almost certainly
not a cult leader that said she does
exhibit a cult e characteristic here and
there most notably in expecting her
volunteers to work long grueling hours
for zero dollars in devotion to her
cause I don't pay anybody to do animal
fear because people will do that for
free also her whole uniform thing is
pretty much textbook cult material our
volunteers wear a color-coded shirt
system after they've been here for like
five years or so they can graduate to a
that's blue that's a navy blue there's
royal blue I'm actually an intern you
can find an exact analogy in nexium
which ranked its member status by
colored sashes obviously being stoked
about your uniform doesn't mean you're
in a cult
but the members devotion to a rigid
hierarchy as decreed by Carroll
indicates a certain subservience to her
mission of course it's worth asking
aren't some of these tactics say of
bullying people into changing their
behavior employed in say your local
CrossFit class aren't you basically
paying to work for your local Improv
Theater we'll fork over five hundred
dollars for an advanced class that
includes performing for paying audiences
what about multi-level marketing schemes
that ostensibly offer you meaning and
economic emancipation so long as you're
willing to buy $20,000 worth of tie-dyed
leggings we'd argue that the incessant
human quest for meaning is capable of
being exploited by any charismatic
leader in almost every area of human
life even that of certain YouTube celebs
though we certainly won't name names
whether we're prostrating ourselves to
the soul cycle instructor or dedicating
our lives to climbing up the ranks of a
multi-level vitamin company we're all
guilty of subsuming or independence in
the name of a common goal often while
being marshaled by the words of a
seductive leader even if our life isn't
being run by a traumatic narcissist
we're all capable of being whipped into
cult-like frenzies and it's certainly
not a bad thing to find a cause you
believe in unless you lose your autonomy
there's a difference between
volunteering for Doctors Without Borders
versus moving to spawn ranch with
Charles Manson but you know if a guy
with a mullet offers you a trailer to
live in in exchange for a lifetime of
servitude maybe just try to find meaning
in your local fantasy football league
instead hell I'd even recommend
SoulCycle but what do you think
wisecrack are we reading too much into
the Gospel of Joey's attic and DA cantle
or are they fully 100% cult material and
is the search for meaning inherent in
all of us a big part of what makes Tiger
King so damn addictive let us know what
you think in the comments a huge thanks
to our patrons for supporting the
channel and our podcasts hit that
subscribe button and as always thanks
for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]